what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
first Colin show from the new studio
it's actually been a couple of months
since I've done one of these things one
of these shows before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
video videos like the video on your way
in subscribe to the channel okay
so today's topic
we are talking about modern marriage and
modern solutions so I have a couple of
stats that I have prepared for you and I
want to get you guys's takes on what are
the solutions to Modern dating today so
in 1970 the average age of first
marriage was 23 for men and 20 for women
now it is 28 and 29. the average length
of a relationship
before engagement is two to five years
and the average wedding costs twenty
thousand dollars
so I looked this up and it's about 12K
on the low end and 30k on the high end
so
on one hand from the women I hear if a
man loves you then he'll marry you
immediately
or he'll know right away however that
doesn't really match up with what I'm
seeing because the average the average
time it takes for someone to get engaged
is two to five years
um
Okay so
now we've also talked about on this
channel how
prevalent single motherhood is but on
the other hand we also see that marriage
is a bad contract that men don't want to
sign so the problem is these conflict
each other right if we don't get married
then we have single mothers and we have
more baby mamas however I also see the
case for men walking away from
relationships and not wanting to get
married because it is a bad contract for
men that women are paid to leave
the average length of marriage is seven
to eight years
so
and I'm pretty sure I've seen a couple
things that say that they file about two
years before so it seems like the
average length that they date before
they're they're married actually is
around is similar to when they actually
get married
so on one hand we say that's a bad
contract but we also say it doesn't
count unless you have a ring so this has
me drawing the question of how do we
move forward in the future so I've
written down a couple modern solutions
for men and modern solutions for women
that I've observed this is not me
telling you what to do this is just what
I've seen that people are doing today so
I want you guys in the comment section
and to call in and tell me which what
you see as the future moving forward
this is what I have come up with
and if I if I've missed anything feel
free to put that in too so modern
solutions for men
um you live together no legal marriage
but you have a ceremony
with your friends and family but you
don't sign the government contract you
could do marriage with a prenup
no prenup but date the girl for a
certain amount of time and then get
married so in order to offset how risky
marriages maybe you date her for a
longer period of time so that seems to
be what men are doing now they date the
girl for like two to five years and then
get married
um
you could be a bachelor forever spin
plates I don't know a ton about domestic
Partnerships but that seems to be an
option too
and you could just have a long-term
relationship and not live with her
modern solutions for women demand
marriage in the one to two years
demand marriage from men within one to
two years and cut ties if you don't get
it date someone for two to five years in
hopes that they will give you marriage
live with someone
with no marriage
stay in a long-term relationship with no
marriage sign a prenup and get married
so
um this is what I've come up with let me
know in the modern dating landscape men
what do you want to do moving forward
and women as well call in do you have
the call-in Link in the chat
okay so the numbers on screen what do
they do they call it and then you can
put it on the line
okay so actually I don't have the chat
pulled up on my left but let me look
they have to turn oh turn notifications
on yeah make sure you turn my producer
saying to make sure you turn off your
notifications when you call in
but that's pretty much my question guys
because it's like on one hand we have
the women we don't want women to waste
their 20s on men that don't want them
right I mean
that's what they always say they always
say if a man knows he wants to marry you
to get me that he's going to do it
within the first year that's what Kevin
Samuels would say
however at on the other hand it's a bad
contract for men so it's kind of like
where do we go moving forward what do
you guys want to do moving forward so um
you have someone on the line
hello hello hi how are you
good how about yourself I'm good I'm
good
what do you think the solution is moving
forward to modern day dating
honestly I think it all has to do with
both women and men both growing in
virtue I don't think anyone is like
virtuous enough to be married nowadays
either men or women and I think the idea
of marriage has been so skewed now
thanks to how modern society is working
but going back to like how it used to be
I think is the only really way to
reinstitute marriage as a real thing
okay so you think
um
do you think that's probable moving
forward that people are going to go back
to traditionalism
I think there's like a pendulum swinging
in society so right now we're swinging
so far away from traditionalism that
eventually it's gonna have to swing back
because I think everyone's starting to
realize this is not working people are
unhappier than ever I think suicide
rates have been higher than ever before
and
I hope everyone wakes up soon and
realizes this isn't working we need to
go back
okay thank you appreciate you calling in
thank you bye bye
so what do you guys think return to
traditionalism is that the solution
going forward
I am I just turned 26.
um I don't have all the answers so let
me know what you guys think
let me I can't see the live chat for
some reason on my laptop I don't know
why
but let me
yeah you can do another caller
I haven't done a live show in so long
hello
hello how are you
I'm good
oh can you turn down the laptop on your
side
hello
hello
hello hello how are you
okay next caller
um
I'm trying to see the live chat blessing
I can't see it on my laptop
um
hello
hey Pearl it's Doug MPA how's it going
Doug how are you
I'm fantastic this one's a a Leia it is
the very first option you said for men
you have to live together
and have everything like a marriage but
without a legal State contract I think I
thought it used to be a generation or
two of people that just don't do legal
marriages because that's the only way
it's Gonna Change do you think what do
you think about single motherhood do you
think that would encourage like more
single mothers
well so the
and the only Power men have nowadays is
to be able to walk away and so getting
married removes that power away from you
so you have to be able to keep that
power the only way to to do that is to
not get married so I don't think it will
decrease single motherhood because
um women women are going to walk away
anyway like women walk away most of the
time it says yeah we'll walk away if
there's less
um you know if it isn't as bad if the
consequences aren't as bad to do so okay
okay
thank you for calling in Doug appreciate
you always good talking to you Pro have
a good one have a good one bye-bye also
guys I wanted to for the woman that said
Return to traditionalism this is just an
interesting stat that people get that
get married before the age of 24
actually 39 more likely to get divorced
so it seems like there's some downside
to getting married younger
um
I don't really have an opinion on it
it's just you know
what the numbers say there's a new one
okay
hello
hello yeah so can I
yeah hi you're live on the air yeah
okay
one second one second make sure your
laptop's off so I can hear myself in
your background like I think you still
have it playing
oh there you go go ahead
what do you think the solution is to
Modern dating moving forward is marriage
outdated
foreign
okay so um thanks I was I was looking uh
to speak to pearly I really like your
hero
this is Pearl
oh okay
um so what do you think the solution is
moving forward to Modern dating do you
think marriage is outdated
so I I think that women today have have
changed so much so that there's no going
back and women are paid for living
marriages women are motive are
incentivized to leave marriages and I've
seen my friends crying today at for
example today my colleague is crying
because his girlfriend just blessed he
told him sorry I don't love you anymore
I'm not in love with you but I I I love
somebody else so she just fell in love
with another colleague and he's crying
and crying so for me I I think that the
things are so [ __ ] up today that the
only solution for men just be a bachelor
and skin plate that's all that's all
it's bad but the the market is already
bad there's nothing we can do about it
women have changed so much that there's
just nothing I have seen my friends
crying their girlfriend leaving them for
absolutely no reason just because they
find another man
and for me uh I mean I quit the dating
Market because I was destroyed by two
women I my heart was increases and I've
seen my friends that are still trying to
date that have been ruined
ah sorry I I think that this game over
marriage is an absolute social construct
and managed to protect themselves either
you stay alone or you you spin to it
that's all thank you okay thank you for
calling in
so we got what one vote for spinning
plates
can you keep track of these blessing I'm
just curious what the demo so it's one
person said go back to traditionalism
one person said spin plates and what did
Doug said Doug said
he said walk away and living with them
without without the contract can you
keep track of how many
each person says
is that okay
you try
okay okay no worries no worries it's
okay
um guys keep track of it in the chat
keep track in the chat okay call in the
next person
okay
um
it's interesting what's the number so
guys if you want to call in
oh yeah you can answer
hi this is Pearl you're live on the air
hey good night
um
my my two cents I think Mario should be
18 year contract
a eight year contract what is it 18
years is because it did 18 years three
as a kid
oh yeah oh that's an interesting idea
hello hi can you hear me yeah yeah you
hear me yeah yeah so you think it should
be an 18-year contract
yes please okay
um that's an interesting idea do you
think that women are entitled to
anything in that 18-year contract and
man like how would that work would it
just be divide the assets you had coming
in
would it be similar to a marriage
contract how would you set it up
you listen what you got coming in
and
basically spit it in half when it's over
or you could just do a renewal
or go for another 18 years
and go for another 18 years okay and
18-year contract what you have come in
what if um the man makes a lot of money
or the woman makes a lot of money is
either entitled to the other's money
that they made during the contract
would it be similar to how marriage is
set up today or what would be different
foreign
but off the top of my head I would say
you
well if you're going to pay a child
support you've got a certain amount that
the government this kind of tier for
child support right
so you kind of based off of that
plug down the calculator for 18 years
and
the lesser of the two will get it
okay
okay that's an interesting idea 18-year
contracts okay thank you for calling in
appreciate you okay
interesting an 18-year contract it seems
okay you can answer go ahead
hello
hey how's it going Pearl I'm good how
are you
good just saw your live stream thought
I'd call in
okay um so what do you think is the
solution for men and for women moving
forward because I've had a lot of
solutions for men so why don't why don't
you give me one for both
so this is actually a funny thing for me
I became a Mormon about 10 years ago
right when like Tinder was uh just
starting up like becoming a thing okay
and when I started watching your show I
saw like how completely different the
dating field is nowadays but I think
probably the biggest thing right now is
that there's no maturity around dating
like people are just dating to have fun
guys are dating to have fun and get as
many girls as they want people aren't
dating for the purpose of marrying and
having kids anymore and and like the LDS
Community that's what we do when we date
we date because we're looking for
somebody to marry instead of somebody to
just have fun around with so it's it's
crazy how much the mentality of dating
has just completely changed in the last
10 years because guys and girls nowadays
they get married when they're running
out of time and they're running out of
options
so what what is the solution to you
moving forward dating with intention
and dating with intention but there's
got to be like a cultural shift like
everyone is viewed families not being
worth anything like family something
that you do after you've had fun instead
of you start your life with the
intentions of having a family so unless
people actually have a reason to get
married there's no point you know if
you're just marrying so that way you
don't want to grow old and lonely that's
it's a pretty sad way to enter marriage
but if you're getting married with the
intention of having a family
you're dating different people than if
you're just looking for somebody to have
fun with so say say we're dating with
the intention of having a family
um do you think men should sign the
marriage contract
100 okay why
uh because when you sign a contract with
men and women when you enter into that
marriage Arrangement you're saying hey
we're going to be together
thicker thin no matter what happens
we're together for the purpose of having
kids raising a family growing all
together and dying together that's what
your intention is when you get married
unfortunately divorce has become so easy
people get married I don't even know why
people get married if they're not
intending to you know right but have a
better purposes what I'm saying from
like a guy's point of view why would you
sign a contract that she's paid to leave
when the divorce rate is 50 like what
incentive does he have
well uh what's the purpose of you
getting married if that's what you're
worried about
and if you're dating the kind of girls
that are going to do that then you need
to find a better dating pool
um
so you think it's all on the on the men
and the women there no it's on both
that's what I'm saying like normal women
that you wouldn't expect still leave
their husbands
so it's like why would a guy sign a
contract where she's paid to leave
that comes down to trust like with my
wife who when we got married about six
years ago like when we got married it
was to create a stable foundation for
our family she could right now I'm in a
place where there's a no-fault divorce
she could at any time leave me but at
the same time like we both have
expectations of each other like I have
expectations for her she has
expectations for me we have to live up
to it and uh one time we were joking uh
when we were engaged we're walking in a
river valley here and we ran into this
old couple and they told us they've been
married 60 years and my wife asked like
hey did you guys ever like think of
divorce or anything and the old lady
just looked at her she's like divorced
she's like never honey murder a few
times no
oh and and I agree with you like I think
that's the ideal but again I just think
right now the laws are the way they are
and is it wise to tell men to sign that
contract with the laws being the way
they are
like I I just personally like have a
hard time encouraging that because again
like men are more likely to commit
suicide after a divorce they could lose
access to their children they could lose
half of their everything they've worked
20 30 years to build up and it's if you
get on a plane and there's a 50 chance
of you
of it crashing are you likely to get on
the plane probably not and like I I
understand like there's different
um in the Mormon Community I'm sure this
isn't as prevalent but it this most
people don't live in that community
and so what is the average guy supposed
to do
oh 100 agree like I said the culture is
completely messed up nowadays outside
like I didn't realize how messed up it'd
become until I started watching your
shows and seeing yeah with the people
you bring off the street actually say
and it just blew my mind yeah but um I
think I think probably
so it's good what's the real solution
going forward me my wife we're open
about talking about this stuff and like
for example like I we've talked about
one time like the number one thing that
triggers divorce is the guy losing his
job
and it's not that my wife would ever
want to like ditch me just because I
lose my job I mean I make a healthy
income she's able to be a stay-at-home
mom but at the same time I know that if
the income stops coming in her
uncertainty is going to go through the
roof and she's gonna eventually just be
her own biology is going to force her to
leave
so and on the flip side you know I I
tell her you know like
I gotta sometimes I'm a little horny and
I want to have sex sometimes and she
understands that and then at the same
time I tell her hey I'm out making the
money you can help my certainty a ton by
taking care of the home making sure the
place is nice doing the classic like
being a home mother kind of situation so
when I come home I'm able I don't come
home to more chaos in my life no and I
agree that and of course we help each
other out no and I I agree that's how it
should be but my question still is what
is the solution moving forward you you
would still say that men should sign a
contract that women are paid to leave
because again like it's it's nice to say
oh in an ideal situation this is how it
should be but we're in modern times
but I'm also a modern times and I like
LDS culture and it's not just LDS but
also like
more Orthodox Christian and uh other
religious groups we still live in the
culture where marriage is a big deal and
it's culturally enforced
so my best advice to men would be to go
and go into a culture where marriage is
valued there's still pockets of it out
there everywhere uh it's not mainstream
you're going to be going into a pool
where there's women and men who have
expectations and you have expectations
so my best advice to guys would be to go
enter into one of those cultures where
there's still that pressure from her
family from your family from the people
in your community to maintain marriage
as what it should be as opposed to going
in out and dating people in a place
where that's not
you know there's no cultural pressure to
stay together because then you're trying
to rely on legal pressure and you know
you see how far that goes
yeah I just I don't know it doesn't
really sit right with me to tell guys to
sign a contract that women are paid to
leave and trust that she won't
and go just go to somewhere where her
friends and her family will tell her not
to
you know
yeah you know I can see
I can honestly tell you if you're
looking at it from a pure legal
standpoint and the only thing that's
forcing you two to stay together is a
legal contract that's easily broken and
there's no point do you need more than
just a legal contract there is a
question in the chat do Mormons have
multiple wives That's a thing in Mormon
is that right
no no there's a break off of our church
that broke off like 100 years ago that
practice is it but uh there's always the
joke you know brother I see you're
lacking wives here take one of mine
okay
I appreciate it
no problem
um
I wanted to see I feel like I saw stat
and I don't want to I wasn't gonna quote
this because I'm not sure and I don't
want to quote anything I'm not 100 sure
of but I swear I saw something that said
that religious people like the marriage
rates aren't a lot better than with the
normal population I don't know Chad if
you know
where that is let me know
I'm gonna look it up after the show
because I'm just curious because okay A
lot of times we get the church right
they'll come in and say return to
traditionalism but
unfortunately as sad as it is I just
don't think there's any going back and
again
people that get married before the age
of 24 or 39 more likely to get divorced
our traditional outcomes better in
modern times
I don't know I don't have all the
answers so that's why I'm saying call in
let me know what you guys think
um
I want to look up the
church marriage I swore it was not that
different but I could I could be wrong I
don't wanna
anyways guys Colin
what'd you say
let's see
so another question that I have
women would you give up a wedding for a
marriage the average wedding cost twenty
thousand dollars would you give up a
wedding for a marriage because that's
one thing I've seen is that guys don't
want to get married because they don't
want to pay for the ring and pay for the
wedding and like pay for like it's so
expensive and why why do you need that
expensive of
a wedding and a ring to get a husband
I'm going to read some of the super
chats so one solution take the
government out of marriage to remove
incentives to walk away marriage is
still a very fulfilling partnership the
best way to stay together is to just
stay together
yeah but you can't help it if your wife
leaves you
what do you
you can't help that
um your WhatsApp call number is not
working
that's what they say I can't find out
how to call but my wife and I got
married as virgins I was broke because
of her and I am now well above 100K
we've been happily married for
uh so say 13 years and happy
okay go ahead
hello
I didn't answer okay
and the other thing is the church has a
lot of single women in it so it's like
if churches and these pockets of society
really and I don't know much about the
Mormon church but I'm thinking like
Christian Catholic
oh there's caller hello you're live on
the air
hey how are you I got through yeah
thanks for taking my call yeah thanks
for calling in what is the solution to
Modern dating moving forward what's your
opinion
um so my opinion is the traditionalism
is kind of out the window
um
if
if modern women want traditional guys
they're gonna have to take on
traditional roles
it's it comes down to that
if modern women want traditional guys
they have to take on traditional roles
do you see that happening
I don't not in this climate especially
politically um
yeah I think the political correctness
is just wreak havoc on the nuclear
family in general it's taking the balls
away from every guy in his house for the
most part
um yeah it's just there's a lack of
respect in the houses now
being said what is the solution for men
going forward do you think they should
spin plates for a lifetime do you think
they should live together no legal
marriage
so I I can't speak for everybody
everybody's situation is different
um my situation is unique in its own um
I'm with a woman who's got two kids
prior to me
um I ended up having a kid with her as
well but knowing that
um
she's going through some things on you
know as everybody does and yeah
everybody's situation is different so
you really can't just make a blanket a
blanket thing that's going to work for
everybody
did you get married or no
no I and I refuse to she wants to
um and we we butt heads because every
time one of her friends gets married off
you know it turns into a big fight in my
house so
um but yeah I mean I've just put my foot
down when she got divorced the last time
she was kicked out of her house
um with the kids and I just you know
everybody has their past
um but I don't see a need to make the
kids suffer for that so we've I
basically set it up to where she could
she was able to purchase this house and
her name with my income
um so she set up no matter what happens
as far as me and her are concerned
um
yes that's just where I'm at I'm not
going to get married though I don't see
any benefit in it and if I if I don't
have to stay illegally you know because
marriage is just a contract if I don't
have to stay legally and I do shouldn't
that mean more to somebody
yeah oh that's interesting yeah probably
she could
I think I think the way like women look
at it
is
I don't know we're always going to want
to get married but like I also really
see the men's point of view where it's
like what incentive do you guys have to
do that nowadays
I mean he was married and I was married
uh I was in the military and anybody
who's in the military knows getting
married's common
you know even in my my family's history
that my parents didn't stay together uh
most of the most of the my cousins my
Aunts Uncles they've all split up so
just from my experience what I've
witnessed it's just there's no point to
it
do you think people stay together longer
if they don't get married just not data
or anything just personal experience
I'm saying I'm sorry sir do you think
people
um state that you know stay together
longer if they're not married not data
or anything just personal experience do
the people that are just dating seem
happier than the married people that you
know I'm just curious the comparison
yeah I mean that's a good question I
don't think I've ever really thought of
that
um
I would say there's not as much stress
on the guy's side
if it's not continuously pushed on him
like if a guy wants to get married he's
going to get married he's going to ask
you
um that's kind of the last bit of
control we have in this in the matter
what do you think we can't we can't tell
them not to have a kid like I had I've
got a two-year-old now and I wouldn't
change it for anything because it
changes your world but I didn't want
kids coming into this
so it's like she took that option away
from me and I'm not being spiteful
because this was my decision from the
beginning whether I had a child with her
or not I'm just not getting married
again
what do you think of women
um giving men ultimatums because
something that I heard from Kevin
Samuels was you shouldn't date a guy
longer than say a year if he doesn't if
you want to be married
um the goat yeah yeah and you always
hear the if he wanted to he would marry
you if he really loved you he would
marry you but it's like from what I've
seen I see a lot of guys date girls for
a long period of time and I really do
think they love them and want to be with
them but it just seems like marriage
isn't in their best interest so what do
you what do you think of that
I think you kind of nailed it on the
head I think that's kind of what it is
there's just really no benefit for the
guy anymore I mean at this point for for
my particular situation
I mean how much is it is a wedding we're
gonna take that off of your table here I
mean we we're not we're living together
we're basically married thank God I live
in this state because there's no common
law
um otherwise I that would be a thing
eventually that I could get myself into
some legal issues later on if we did
split so really I think it's more guys
are just trying to protect themselves
for as long as they can what if your
girl said
um I just want to be your wife I don't
care about the wedding would you do it
then or no
I don't understand what's the benefit I
mean she's not I agree all right so this
is my particular situation she's not a
woman of Christ you know we've had a
child out of wedlock she was married
before what are you getting at like what
for who
that's funny
does that make sense yeah no I mean she
wants to go if she wants to go to the
courthouse and change her last name go
for it
oh that's funny not a woman of Christ
okay thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
all right thanks have a good one not a
woman to cry
um
okay okay I'll tell them guys so
um when when you call in when I'm on the
phone we can't answer it so you have to
wait till we're done is that though the
beeping is in the background I see so so
in order this we're we're new to the
live show Colin so in order to make this
the highest quality show possible
please call after he hangs up
after after we hang up okay I know I
know it's hard to get on the phone so
like you want to keep calling but just
do it after they hang up okay you can
take the next you can call now take the
next caller
it's interesting though because
are they on
okay okay hello this is Pearl you're
live on the air
hey Pearl this is AJ how you doing today
I'm good how are you
good good good yeah so I was uh I love
you your show it's great the Topic's
awesome but I really don't think really
men need need to do much on our end
because if you see the eviction rates in
the US with seriously black women are up
and through the roof and now Generation
X is uh the biggest group of women that
either didn't get married didn't have
kids or their kids are are grown so now
you're starting to see homeless homeless
women out there in the streets so
marriage has always been the retirement
plan or economic stability so this is
the first time where you go to
California San Francisco Seattle you see
women in these homeless camps you know
so what's going to happen is that if
there's another big uh you know uh
variant of the you know of the bug or
whatever or any type of economic
downturn when women are doing well men
are doing just fine so as far as as
marriage goes I really think that
especially in the west all of our
countries are very reactive and not
proactive and it's going to take
something like people's basic needs not
getting met women are going to really
need to start because because that's one
thing that I feel that a lot of the
women who are on your show don't get is
they always go oh Pearl women are are
doing it and we're only six percent
women in the United States earned six
figures most women the number one
employer the women is retail so women
are not doing it they're not out earning
men they're not outpacing men they're
not doing well at all and with this
Automation and and retail stores closing
women are up on the streets so I really
think so what do you think that the
solution is for women then moving
forward do you think they
because it's interesting because
a lot of times they'll push getting
married but at the same time tell men
not to
well I think that on women's they need
to understand the Practical benefits to
get married and stay married and then
men need to just like how women try and
withhold sex uh
because they have high standards men
need to make our standards higher for
for marriage okay so for instance you
know go ahead I'm more on the left but I
always tell all of my friends uh dating
us change your your settings to
conservative or find a woman who's from
overseas who has who meets a certain
checklist of of morals and standards if
you're going to choose to marry it at
all you know but you have to as a man
treat your last name like a woman's
supposed to treat her vagina you know
you have to have standards the same
thing so what do you
um
what do you want to get married
some yeah okay would you get married
legally
well the thing is is is this
it depends on the state and it depends
on who you're married to right because
so say say dream girl dream girl every
every check box is checked
huh every box is checked
yeah you would get married legally yes
or no
yes but in Texas
okay Texas are like Wyoming or something
you know what I'm saying okay it's like
the maximum amount of child support that
you have to pay in tax in Texas is like
eighteen hundred dollars or something
like like 2 300 even if if you're some
oil billionaire like Texas I think that
Missouri have it sorted where like
it's really hard well I mean men can
still get screwed over but you get like
the least amount of screwed over in a
lot of red States I I grew up on the
west coast but I honestly think that I'm
gonna have to to move to like the
reddest the red state by the way that
things are going now okay so crazy how
long would you date a girl before
getting married
um
maybe about a year that depends on your
age if you're in your 20s right then I
would say that it takes a little while
to kind of get to know someone uh and
then also you need to kind of have those
life altering events so for instance you
might have to move or do something and
then you kind of see if the person is
that one to be with if you're more in
your 40s or 50s and you're just trying
to move on in life you should probably
know what you want already the 30s it
all depends on if it's like a single mom
which I recommend not dating or
I'm wearing at all but the older that
you get the less time so so older about
a year older about a year it sounds like
about about a year less if you're older
okay okay so um Your solution is to get
married in a conservative state
uh yeah if if you choose to marry if you
first of all it's really most guys I
really think in the west don't get
married but if you choose to because you
want to have kids move to the reddest of
the red state
or uh uh a conservative traditional
chick or a chick who's from an
international I mean country like you
know South America a Muslim woman or
something or any community that has
shame and a stigma for divorce and I
think you'll be all right okay okay
thank you for calling
um just like Pearl Old School Pearl said
bring back shame
thank you thank you
um hold I'm gonna I'm gonna just talk
for one second before you take the next
call okay so these are the solutions we
have I'd just like this to be a group
thing because again
we don't want single mothers we don't
want baby mom like we've agreed that's
bad we you should oh then the next
question do we marry before we carry
if men shouldn't get married then how
can we say Mary before you carry
I I'm just asking questions so but these
are the these are the solutions
live together
with no legal marriage have a ceremony
marriage with the prenup they didn't say
that I said marriage at the prenup no
prenup but date the girl for a certain
amount of time then get married so dater
for for a long amount of time bachelor
life forever spin Place plates domestic
Partnerships long-term relationships but
do not live with her
18-year contract list what you have
coming in split it in half and then go
for it for another 18 years if you want
child support is for a set amount
someone in the chat put cohabitation
agreements is what's is the future
that's interesting idea
um and we got get get married is a
solution
um oh get married in a red State I
didn't finish writing that in a red
state
okay I'll take that and I also want
solutions for women because the question
is we want to marry before we carry but
men shouldn't get married so should
women still demand marriage
are we in a post-marriage society
um anyways um next caller you can do
okay he's gonna open it up
I feel like a lot of people have
thoughts on this
questions because it's like
a lot of the stuff we talk about
conflicts sorry all right go ahead hello
live on the air this is Pearl
hi bro nice to talk to you I think
there's a delay on the YouTube that's
why people are calling all the time
oh okay anyway yeah uh guys like the
video and subscribe
so what's this location going forward to
Modern dating
so I think the best solution for the
problem with marriages to have
conditions for
um
conditions for divorce like to to live
without a reason like a proper reason
where'd he go
oh I think that and you have kids would
be something like that oh okay sorry you
cut out for a second do you think from
what I understood you think there should
be conditions for divorce and you can't
just like we should get rid of no fault
divorce it sounds like
yeah just to have conditions for divorce
like abuse would be one condition to get
divorced physical abuse
mental abuse
and if you have kids
uh I mean that's the conditions if you
have kids if you don't have kids like
you have to make it work like you're
unhappy negotiate with your partner uh I
mean both parties would want to have a
good relationship with each other and if
you're forced to stay with each other
you'll find a way to both be happy one
way or another
mm-hmm
oh can you turn off the YouTube in the
back
yeah sorry
yeah okay thank you do you think that
men should still get married today
uh with the current
uh laws it's a bad deal but if you're
certain your woman is like traditional
or or traditionalist like
I forgot her name
I can't eat like I think that's a good
bet
so your solution for men is get I mean I
I know you can't say for all men but get
married but make sure but vet her make
sure she's a traditionalist
yeah okay all right yeah I mean safest
bet because nowadays people are getting
brainwashed and
do you think social media do you think
women should marry before they carry
yeah there's enough conscious
contraception of on the uh
availability is what control section is
like way above what men can do
no but I'm saying if he doesn't want to
get married but he wants to have a kid
should she do it
uh with uh she should she should marry
before she carries Mary before you carry
it okay thank you for calling in
no worries have a good day thank you I
mean night okay thanks
um okay someone's in the chat hold on
I'm going to talk for a second don't
someone in the chat said Mary After High
School
again again I like the idea of that my
parents met After High School however
people that get married before the age
of 24 are 39 more likely to get divorced
this was I was surprised by the stat
however
does this produce better outcomes it
doesn't seem to
so
again anyways
the you can open the phone lines again
do you have it open
okay guys you can call in again
I was married at 22 and have been
married for over 33 years I'm not saying
it could be the best solution going
forward
I don't know I don't have all the
answers so I'm asking you guys
nothing beats Young Love married between
24 and 30. prenups can be overturned
because that's the other question we say
Mary before you carry
and I agree I like the idea of that but
can you really blame men for not wanting
to get married and if you're with a guy
that doesn't want to get married for
that reason
should you carry should you carry and
not get married oh that kind of Rhymes
should you carry and not get married I'm
not I'm not promoting it one way or the
other
Kevin Samuel said that marriage is
becoming an elite institution because of
money
yeah oh do you have someone
hello this is Pearl you're live on the
air
all right turn off the YouTube in the
background
yeah yeah oh yeah cut it off okay can
you hear me yeah yeah hi how are you
hi
um yeah why not I can keep my two cents
I guess about that kind of the situation
you you kept on asking people for giving
like also like a take on the women's
side so I would try to do that as well
um as well in general like I think maybe
uh as of today a lot of people don't see
marriage I'm not so talking solely uh on
traditional people as a relative thing
as much as in the past
um okay and because of it like I I know
like I'm not I'm not young and uh or not
that young I guess anymore and uh a lot
of my friends a lot of people that I
know around me just don't marry uh and
not only like because of like the the
issues a lot of people are not aware of
like the risk of like you know the
things that you bring up as uh oh it's
like a a trap for men or something just
in general like you know people just see
this Lassa
um
uh thing that you want to get dragged
into because of the risk in general
um
so um I guess like you know uh when you
said like about saving it so the idea is
like if whether it's like uh savable or
like if it's neat it needs to be saved I
would say like only like if you consider
like you know the idea of having kids
and that kind of stuff and and looking
at the kid as a
the kids is the reason to to even try to
save it because otherwise like
personally if I find the connection and
as other people said like uh I wouldn't
say that I need to be married in order
to consider it like as a good connection
like a lifelong connection I don't need
the stem form a state or a church in
that regard can you hear me by the way
yeah I can hear you so if men if men do
want a family do you think they should
get married what what modern solution do
you think men should do going forward
well I vote for better politicians I
guess okay so so and walk away from
Marriage until the laws change
um are you saying walk away from
Marriage until the laws change
you know that's definitely something
that like men should be wary of that and
yeah uh and um yeah till they get it I
mean like unfortunately a lot of people
gonna play into the system and then in
case and they're gonna
um play into the system they're gonna
probably like kept hurting like other
men that they will try like to get into
that uh so you can't really do anything
too much just avoid it as I guess like
till it changes is one thing
um or like prenups is kind of like maybe
as a thing that like some people I know
like I have a few friends that did it uh
it it helps it's better than nothing
although like it makes things awkward
obviously especially when you are
younger and it's just like oh
yeah because like do you feel like kind
of like a fairy tale idea of marriage
like for a lot of people especially in
younger ages uh and it it definitely
like hard to see yourself as a young
person
uh getting divorced what do you think
about women should women marry before
they carry
um you mean that they uh
uh what do you mean like it gets
pregnant I mean like before getting like
yeah because on one hand a lot of people
in this space say don't get married or
walk away from Marriage till the laws
change which I understand I agree but at
the same time like then should women
still married before they carry
should they be okay with a long-term
relationship without marriage
um
yeah it's tough so this is why I wanted
like to give my take about like women
signed I guess so the problem is like
obviously there's a lot of uh nowadays a
lot of uh you would say like liberal
woman or that kind of stuff and I'm like
definitely like be the last one like to
to show any hate or like any issues with
that as uh uh but uh
but there's obviously like the
conservative women and for the liberal
ones a lot of them will be like hey uh
maybe they don't don't want a kids they
are like uh claim they want like uh
equality and that kind of stuff they
don't really they'll be like I guess
kind of finding this situation that like
things out at the moment I guess till
they're not
which is uh so like so I just I need a
more direct answer to the question
should women marry before they carry
um I I think like I mean they they
should I mean like in general like you
know you wanna
uh you don't wanna so yeah like you
don't want to have a kid before I think
you're getting married unless you know
that you're never gonna marry unlike
officially but like obviously I would
say like if you want to have kids I mean
build the best house for that
okay thank you for calling out thank you
thank you for calling in
thank you
okay you got it
um you have the next one
because blessing it's an interesting
convo
what do you think blessings you've got
should they marry before they carry
is the phone stressing you out
why are they stressing you out
is 150
for per minute oh wow
okay you can you can open it up
I'm curious in the chat okay should
women marry before they carry if men
don't want to get married
women should definitely marry marriage
as a W for women
hello
hello how's it going I'm good how are
you this is Pearl you're live on the air
what is the solution to Modern dating
going forward for men and for women
so I believe in one or two solutions I
think either one we need to normalize
getting married without the state's
involvement
that would be my first answer or two if
we need the state's involvement we need
to set up license renewals the same way
a driver's license need to be renewed a
gun license needs to be renewed it's
interesting you know I think marriage
license should be renewed and if you
choose not to renew it you shouldn't
need to involve the courts and both
parties should walk away scot-free
oh that's an interesting idea I've never
thought of that
like a license renewal what do you think
should women with the way the laws are
now should they require marriage before
they carry
so yes and no yes that's good advice for
women but no for men
to more a liability if I'm being honest
okay so if you had a daughter and she
said I'm with a guy he wants to have
kids in a family but he doesn't want to
get married legally would you tell her
to stay or go
I would tell her to go okay
it's interesting how the advice
conflicts each other
so why why would you tell her to go that
way but it does why would you tell her
to go if you can understand why men
don't want to get married like that
seems reasonable
so I would I would simply tell her to go
because it's going to be in her best
interest now in terms of uh the man
himself obviously I'd have to meet him
and there would have to be if he thought
the exact same way that I did and I
could relate to him on a
person-to-person level I'm open to
exceptions
um but for the most part as a general
rule of thumb just speaking in general I
would advise her to go okay do you think
men
if he loves you he'll marry you do you
think that's true
no I don't think that's true
um I think that he'd be willing to marry
you but it really just depends on the
circumstances in regards to finance in
regards to his perception of the U.S law
um you know there's there's a lot
there's a lot more variables now that we
have social media we have YouTube we
have people like you obviously Kevin
Samuels everybody educating you know
young men I think it's going to become
more and more common for men to hesitate
towards marriage
how long do you think is too long for a
girl to be waiting for a ring
yeah I mean it's
um it's tough so if if it's from me
giving the advice to my daughter
um I would say 10 years that's going to
be too long
okay so you'd be okay with your daughter
waiting five
yeah if she's young obviously if she's
in her late 20s and she's gonna have to
uh act a lot more quickly especially if
she wants to have children but yeah I'm
assuming she's young 20 years old 19 20.
yeah absolutely okay well thank you for
calling in appreciate it
yeah no problem take care thanks you too
the the freaking marriage renewal that
is such an interesting idea
I've never thought this is why I opened
the call lines
because there's stuff I never would have
thought of never would have thought of
that
um
okay guys call and should women marry
before they carry
oh is
um turning your YouTube off in the
background you're live on the air this
is Pearl
hello
okay next color
hello
hi
this is Pearl you're live on the air
what is the solution to Modern dating
going forward for men and for women
oh
my name is James
um
personally I've been viewing things in a
kind of separative situation marriage
has always kind of been overseen by our
government of power so the argument of
removing it from either state or church
is kind of
a misnomer to me
um
but
there is a I believe the problem is
perception
um we kind of view marriage as
the defining Act of commitment
and
I think we need to
bring a kind of understanding
of
how
uh commitment and marriage are separate
things because marriage has always been
to support a household or family
um and that changes depending on the
environment that you reside in a the the
age the
um
Nation the culture wherever you are at
that changes what uh the needs of a
group what do you mean can you tell me
more about the difference between
commitment and marriage
well commitment is your is your personal
decision to be committed to one to an
individual or anything and that uh
doesn't have to be that one person
um it
being committed means you're committed
to this thing so if it's a relationship
you're committed to that relationship if
you're committed to your job whatever
it's you're committed to it marriage
um is taking on extra
uh characterizations to support
the things that come along with that so
um if you have a family marriage it
helps you whether it be taxes or
um household environment stability there
are benefits to come with it that's
always been the case with marriage
so what do you think the solution is
going forward should men get married
uh
no the solution I I'm thinking or going
or going for is um to
re re-understand and Define how we view
such relationships and marriages
um
to make it easier to conceptualize and
restore
um the kind of balance it when we have
government involvement because there
always will be in some fashion
government or organization like the
church there'll always be right now it's
all it's war is so one-sided and it's
and it's incentivized to
kind of disrupt it
um
uh disrupt marriage because walking away
for a woman uh comes with so many
benefits right we need to restore
um that one so it's actually
incentivized to maintain a marriage
but also have the perception that
marriage itself is to support
um things to bring in extra extra
benefits and extra
um
Aid that's it's not the defining one
that makes commitment your own choice at
being committed is what defines
commitment marriage is a helping hand in
in a way
um because that's what you're doing when
you get married you're like hey cool
we're married can I have these benefits
you know do you think women should marry
before they carry
foreign
logical to fully expect that anymore in
our current uh in the new climate of the
modern era
um to just have that expectation anymore
I don't think it's logical
okay there's been too many benefits no
and that's the thing
I really don't like saying that like it
kind of puts like it makes me feel a
certain type of way but I understand it
because yeah it's like what incentive do
men have to marry you nowadays
yeah that right now there's no actual
incentive to me to marry because we
don't gain anything uh from the act of
marriage aside from you know telling the
world hey I love this person that's
pretty much the only incentive we have I
mean there are some like tax breaks and
stuff that we get to now take advantage
of but
it's a very limited scope whereas the
other side gets a lot more benefits and
upon the destruction of a marriage if
that occurs
once one side is massively that
destruction is almost completely
one-sided
um
so there's not really any incentive to
get married in the western world and and
mostly the modern world in general but
if we restore the legalities and bring
and bring back more balance uh for
instance uh one brought up the idea of
putting back into effect like uh taking
away a no-fault divorce I don't think
instead separating fault and no fault
giving a kind of option and saying like
if you're taking no fault divorce you're
gonna get less back out of that you know
because you're walking away by choice
and having a separate one for fault
divorce where if something went
massively wrong that was out of your
control well now those other things that
you would do that would be open to you
in general now are now a thing so
because
first fault divorce and no fault divorce
and you there's two different incentives
okay that's an interesting idea
that's an interesting idea because if
you want to walk away that's a choice
you should be able to make I mean if you
don't care or love about love a person
anymore being stuck with them is gonna
breed hostility but being incentivized
to do so because the option to just walk
away makes every single problem that
occurs in a relationship that much more
appealing it's there like you could just
oh cool uh you we had a fight today so
uh buy I'm Audi 5000 and that's a total
option but if you have both you know no
fault and fault divorce and if on the
no-fault one you're walking away doesn't
give you all the benefits of I don't
know alimony and stuff like that like
you walk away means I hope you can
support yourself and get your own job
right now if you're not working or
whatever or you have your own place you
don't get to take the house if you
didn't pay for it you know those
benefits that would come with a natural
like a actual divorce now
then you're not incentivized to just
walk and it still leaves you the option
to do so and then there's also fault
divorce where if you are in an abusive
relationship and the dude just
beats the hell out of you you can go yo
he just knocked the crap out of me and
now the punishment has is able to fit
the crime essentially okay thank you for
calling in appreciate it
no problem have a good one
um
foreign
fault and no fault
you have the next one blessing also oh
wait here I'll do I'll do that
announcement after hi this is Pearl um
you're live on the air what is the
solution to Modern dating
hello
oh um
did you hang up oh hello
can you hear me yeah I can hear you go
ahead
hey pearl big fan uh I got the solution
to Modern uh dating
uh peach uh as men turn women into
misogynist
teach them to be uh wives like as
parents like you're supposed to teach
your kids and you're you're especially
your daughters how to treat men in the
house that's how my parents treated me
and my one my sisters yeah but we can't
change society right so we're in modern
we're in modern times
so do you think that men should just
sorry let me ask the question a
different way should men if they find a
girl that they deem to be quality sign
the marriage contract
[Music]
um
if they find somebody that they deem of
a quality woman then yes they should get
married because that's that's a good
thing for society to have strong family
and strong families
that like who's teaching young men what
a quality woman is
so when they go out and they go out into
the world and they vet whatever women
they meet how do they know what a
quality woman is just because she has a
low body count or just because she's
good looking and in shape or something
like that doesn't mean that they are
quality women
what what is a quality woman to you
to me a quality woman is somebody that
is loyal
um that is loving caring loyal uh
respectful and that uh
doesn't embarrass me and put in front of
public that all basically she needs to
make my life
better in every way
do you think that women can pretend to
be quality
in order to get marriage
yes they can but do you think some guys
to if okay so if you are a woman that is
pretending to be quality woman a quality
woman and you're vetted by somebody that
knows what a quality woman is I
guarantee you there's no way she can
hide it so how long should a guy vet a
girl before considering marriage
I think a good solid two years that's
what my marriage was I I spent uh two
years as
uh
serious relationship and you know
anything that I would have noticed
um that was off either by the way she
treats her parents the way she treats
her friends the way she treats me
um the the her spending habits the way
that she interacts with uh people at
work the way that she responds to a okay
to a request that I have so your
solution is to still get married look
for the quality woman but vet them for
at least two years for men
I I think that
I think that ultimately it is better for
society that if if men marry women the
problem is that in society like I said
we don't know young men don't know what
a quality woman is and the way to fix
that is to have shows like your sh like
your show and other shows that are
around the internet to teach young men
what a quality a real quality woman is
and that would probably fix a lot of the
problems that we have
um unfortunately like the previous
callers have said they have so many
things that
of like they have so many women have so
many benefits for getting divorced that
you could be a quality woman
and be a good happy relationship and
then all of a sudden you know hang out
with the wrong friends or like get
something in your head that like makes
it to where all of a sudden you're like
quote unquote not happy and decide to
leave and then you're incentivized for
it so I think also taking away the
incentives for people that especially
for women that uh get divorced just
because I think that's another solution
too so we take away the but right now we
can't individually change the laws right
so the laws are the way they are so
moving forward
do you think that we can still build
families without marriage
can we build families without marriage
yeah without at least legally
I
yes you can I do not approve of it like
you said I don't think women should
carry kids before marriage okay okay
thank you for calling I don't yes you
can because the family all it takes is
commitment by both parties right but
I still think that marriage is I don't
know I'm religious so I think marriage
is the way you're supposed to do it okay
thank you for calling in
um okay wait wait a second for the next
okay
it's quality women still divorcement all
the time too wake the hell up the money
we pay women to quit that's morally
wrong because that's other I should have
asked this I didn't think of it till now
but that's the other thing like
if women aren't religious like I don't I
don't know that many
I don't want to say I I do know
religious women from
like where I grew up
however
I don't think the majority what percent
blessing what percent of women you think
are religious nowadays like actually
religious
you meet 100 women
five
okay
yeah so five percent of women are
religious does it make sense
to have religious outcomes also guys go
just quick announcement mid-show
um we are going to barber shops and hair
salons in London this week to do
interviews and if you guys have one in
London you want us to go to message it
to my Instagram just pearly things one
they banned my Instagram so go follow it
yeah
um
I want to see if there's any super chats
I haven't read one second let me refresh
the page
um also guys the super chats we actually
got all of the equipment that blessing
needed right blessing
yeah
so all all super chats
what are we gonna buy next
we got a bunch of cameras a bunch
why are you laughing what do you want
blessing
what are you what's in your head I see
it
no no what is it what is it
well we need more lights
what kind of Lights do you want
what's a monopod
oh it's like the one that's sturdy uh
okay how much does that cost
yeah okay guys we're trying to raise um
it's like 400 US Dollars this show from
for blessings monopods so if you want to
send super chats
for a monopod okay mgtow by Logic soon
because men will be so against marriage
women will push for laws giving them the
right to force a man to marry her write
it down oh my God I could see that
happening
um tyquil the I think this was
inappropriate because someone deleted it
um GTI Pete thank you for the super chat
um Nelson Gonzalez I can find out I
can't find out how to call but my wife
and I got married as virgins and I was
broken because of her oh I read this one
already
um I think total guys we have 10 20 25
35 45 55. roughly
60 dollars so
feel free to send super chats to get
blessing of mono something monopod
anyways
marriage is just a piece of paper it's
imaginary that's from Marriage causes
divorce you can open up the phone lines
again
hello hi this is Pearl you're live on
the air
hi
um
sorry uh I don't think um yes can you
hear me yeah yeah go ahead
um I I don't think uh there's a a real
solution until women start marching and
changing laws and
they're the ones that kind of have to
change the culture because they're not
they're not listening to men generally
speaking women have no idea what men
want
um so until they start learning what men
want and they start changing the laws in
the culture I don't think there's an
immediate solution I think it'll
probably take a whole nother generation
what do you think should women
marry before they carry
yes
and that and I think that would be a
start you know like if they're not you
know having you know
you know body count of 10 20 or hundreds
and they're having only seriously or
serious relationships
um that would be a start
but
it would have to be it's going to take
time you know like
I think a lot of the guys that are
calling like um like the Mormon guy a
lot of the religious stuff is always
mentioned and that's that's not a
solution uh that's been mentioned for at
least a generation and that's why guys
don't go to church generally speaking
anymore is because you know there's a
whole bunch of single mothers or or used
up women you know who wouldn't be good
wives you know they're not wives so I
think the stars that women have to
become wives
and take relationships seriously because
they're the ones that I think
disproportionately get affected more
it's actually pretty sad
um
how women are kind of doing this to
themselves you know that they've been
lied to with all the feminism and
everything and
you know a lot of the guests are calling
you know saying that marriage is
uh best for society which is true
but
you know
I don't you know that's kind of like
blue pill thinking you know like we're
like yeah that's the best for society
but that's just putting everything on
hope you know and it's not long so you
know so if marriage isn't changed things
so if marriage isn't a good deal for men
today how can women require marriage
before they carry if a reasonable man it
seems like a guy a reasonable guy
wouldn't get married
that's true
um I see it and that's why I say it's
going to take a long time there's going
to be a lot of women unfortunately that
will probably have to be hurt and you
know and not be able to have you know
families or marriage until you know the
story gets out or it affects the culture
to where guys are like oh you know so
and so dump me you know like we're you
know it's kind of like a common story or
a common theme you know where guys are
constantly running into this you know
where
women only want to date seriously and so
on and so forth
um
but I think a huge Plus for women would
be to
you know then get together and and start
changing laws I mean there there's been
a couple of successes here and there in
certain states in America but as a whole
it's it's not getting any better anytime
soon
well thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
what are you using is it just WhatsApp
did you answer um hi this is Pearl
you're live on the air
yo yo finale harder to find a [ __ ]
virgin in the streets and get on this
[ __ ] call excuse my language
um hi what is the solution to Modern
dating going forward
uh number one uh everything that happens
in society falls on the man so uh men
have to stop being samps
um they're complaining about laws on the
books
they got to start reading and uh change
the laws in the book get in positions of
power out here in California there's too
many uh no offense but there's too many
females
in positions of power you know and it's
because men have been a accustomed to
watching video games instead of working
on houses and uh you know watching
sports and [ __ ] all day long
um so for the average guy that doesn't
want to get into politics should he get
married
uh I would say uh
probably not just because uh most men
they can't handle women
as far as like uh the average man you
know and I think that's a problem with
the red pill space is that a
they teach they're like oh yeah oh man
can uh can handle women and everything
but
not really like I mean they try to use
biblical examples but most of the men in
the biblical days they were uh they were
pretty much like kings they had harems
of a whole bunch of women so the average
man was a slave for the most part you
know
what do you think should women marry
before they carry
yeah I do agree with that because uh
marriages are the the backbone to
society you know so if you're uh if
you're carrying somebody's uh seed who
you can to
can't see a future with it doesn't
really make sense right how long should
a woman wait till marriage or how long
should a woman wait to get marriage
before cutting it off
I'd say like what one of the other guys
said probably like around like two or
three years two or three years it just
depends on how uh good a relationship
she has with her father because if she
doesn't have a good relationship with
her father then
yeah it's over it's over with pretty
much okay
so you think the solution going forward
average guys shouldn't get married
women no but women should get married
before they carry but and they should
leave after three years
well I wouldn't say the average guy
shouldn't get married I would just like
go in a little deeper uh in detail with
that and say the average men shouldn't
expect it you know average man the thing
is like what the red pill space too is
like they how they hype up all these
land mass dudes and it's like bro like
you don't even know how to change your
oil on your vehicle [ __ ] like that you
know and it's like how do you I mean
there's an old saying that my grandpa
used to tell me you know if you want
your wife to stay in the kitchen you
better know how to build and maintain
the kitchen right you know so simple as
that you know as if you don't know if
you don't know what you're doing don't
expect good results
okay thank you for calling in
I have a good one bye um give it a
second blessing
someone in the chat
here's the solution and it says right in
the vowels to death do us part
who are these women marrying themselves
okay you can do another one you can let
them call in
yeah I don't know how we get rid of the
beeping we have to figure that out for
next show hi this is Pearl you're live
on the air
hello this is Pearl you're live on the
air
oh hello Hi how are you
I'm good thank you it was really easy to
get on
what is the solution to Modern dating
going forward
okay
so the solution to Modern dating is
really the younger generation needs to
understand how much our promiscuous
Lifestyles have messed up gen Z like
everybody is so mentally and emotionally
damaged and they have trust issues and
daddy issues and broken families and all
of these bad things and I think the
younger generation needs to like just
completely re-virginize
and just wait until marriage to have sex
okay so kind of say the older people
you're too far gone
you it's it's over with done with but
the young people wait till you're
married
yeah you know I mean
I would like to say that there's hope
for the older people I just think that
you know gen Z is just damaged already
like a lot of the damage has been done
and so I think to kind of fix the dating
arena is to kind of look ahead and look
towards the younger generation and
hopefully because I kind of see you know
like there's this pattern of the younger
generation learns from the older
generation and so I think they'll kind
of see how we've messed that up and then
hopefully they'll just wait until their
Merit until they get married to have sex
I mean if you really think about it like
just hypothetically speaking imagine if
everybody in the world waited until
marriage to have sex or at least
everybody in America and I know you're
in the UK but like if everybody just
waited until marriage to have sex like
how much
how much less problems there would be
like there would be less Brokenness less
cheating less trust issues there would
be less kids out of wedlock there'd be
less abortion I mean we could talk about
contraception too because I know you've
had a lot to say on that and I agree
with you in a lot of ways so what do you
think that men should sign the marriage
contract with a virgin
with the incentives that pay women to
leave
you know
let's see
I think I think yeah like I think if
they can find a good wholesome girl I
mean I'm religious and I'm I'm a
traditional woman I've got a husband
I've got two kids I'm only 23. like you
know and we have a great marriage so I
think
if people can if men can find a good
girl who is
most likely religious because let's be
honest that's where they are
and they're virgins when they get
married and they value like traditional
outcomes you know like they want to be
there for the husband support their
husband they want to be their peace and
do all the things that men want
then I say why not if you know that This
Woman's never going to leave you then
why not as long as you're in it together
so if so you think that men should only
marry virgins
I could be wrong I'm just asking do you
think like they should only offer that
contract to women that are virgins
not only I don't think only because I
think there are a lot of women
um myself included who were not virgins
when we got married but we were kind of
lied to by
by you know the whole secular media and
everybody around us who was not virgins
when they got married and you kind of
get lied to and you're sold this lie as
long as you don't believe in the lie and
you understand that that's not the way
to go and the things that you've done
are wrong in your past but you have to
be willing to accept the fact that you
are wrong and you're going to be better
moving forward because I do believe that
people can change so then do you think
that they should wait till they're
married moving forward
yeah I think so I mean even if you have
a high body count like where you're just
gonna be like if it
is she still there I think it kind of
just oh there your body count
I think that's only gonna hear me yeah I
hear you sorry you cut out for a second
can you hear me yeah yeah okay yeah
she cut out again keep upping their body
count already high well yeah but why
would a guy marry a girl like wouldn't
he kind of be a simp then like if the
last guy got to hit it for free last 10
guys got to hit it for free and then he
marries her like that that like because
I think this is a lot of the issue that
men have with like women that are
religious is like you were kind of
encouraging bad deals for men
oh
um wait hold on wait did you already
accept it
oh yeah okay okay because here's the
thing like
that's that's the problem is like a lot
of times as women I just think we're
really attached to the idea of marriage
and it's not a great deal for men if
you're not a virgin to wait like why
would a guy wait for you and will you
really respect him if he does
and I mean people people can say they
will but I've seen the way these girls
move around their husbands in the church
a lot of times a lot of times but
you know maybe it is the solution I
don't know
um you can open the call lines again
wait so what what did she say she said
wait till we're married basically and
save the young people hello this is
Pearl you're live on the air
oh hi this is Pearl you're live on the
air
hello can you hear me good yeah I can
so um I wanted to kind of answer your
last question about like isn't that a
raw deal for the guy like you know if
she's gotten with you know 10 guys and
then she decides that
you know she doesn't want to be that way
anymore she wants to wait till marriage
yeah yeah go ahead
so I think it depends on how you look at
it right like if she's come to a like
point in a realization that you know
sleeping with all these guys isn't
fulfilling her and she's
you know done you know self-evaluation
and healing right and like understanding
her value I really think that the issue
today is a lack of self-value right or a
lack of valuing love
so like if she's come to that point
she's grown right so let's say she
hasn't slept with someone for two years
now she's been working on herself and
then she meets another guy like I think
that's a different picture right where
she really wants to make it work with
this guy but she's learned that like you
know just letting him have it you know
on the third date or whatnot doesn't
lead to that serious relationship who
determines what's valuable
well I would say like value comes like
it's mixed with morality right like so
like
you know being quote unquote good right
like do you lie cheat and steal right
like how do you carry yourself like are
you one way in front of other people are
you like different behind closed doors
like when I talk about value like
valuing myself if I'm talking personally
like I knew I had been through a lot of
BS in my life and guys and
um so even before meeting my husband I
said like I'm not going to be with
anybody for two years like that's it I'm
not doing like one night stands I'm not
doing anything like I don't I can't even
be in a relationship with anybody like
my picker is off because the last guy I
was with was abusive and I realized that
I picked I was picking people that I was
trying to save right like I can't save
and like fix them if I'm effed up and
I'm picking people that are gonna hit me
right or be this way so I just said like
no I'm not going to be with anyone and I
met my now husband and we you know we
had sex before marriage and
like I've loved him since day one you
know I knew he was gonna be my husband
but he swore he would never get married
again you know but like but you didn't
but you didn't make him do the internal
healing and also like lead him into more
healing as well and like we've healed so
so you had sex with him before you were
married
yeah but yeah yeah but that's what I'm
saying like you didn't require marriage
to have sex with him
and so I just think if I was in a
delusion you know and like you were
entering wages war against the soul and
like what do you mean you're in a
delusion and it's not
a delusion sorry this just doesn't make
any sense to me uh because it's like
like when you're brought up in the
delusional world like you think like you
need to have sex before you get married
to find out if you even want to be with
this person
but but I'm saying so you got the
outcome of marriage and you had sex
before you were married with your
husband I just want to make sure I'm
understanding it
yeah yeah but like for a year and a half
before we got married finally like I
kept hearing in my mind like you should
be married you know and I like I knew I
should but I didn't feel like I could
bring it up with him which is which is
I'm not judging you I'm just saying that
like to me that makes sense because you
weren't a virgin so of course you're
gonna have sex like why would you make
the next guy wait when you let the last
guy have it for free but from a man's
point of view like why on Earth would he
wait for a marriage for a woman that's
not a virgin why would he take why would
he take every possible risk legally
where you can take the kids you can take
the house you can take the money when
again he doesn't even get a virgin at
the end of it
right
like if she has a higher understanding
of healing and like her value at that
point like so she's but she's not but
see you say her value she's not valuable
to men if she's had a whole phase it's
like you can't just magically make it go
away in your values more it's less and
so it's like you're acquiring a higher
price for a worse product
depend but see it depends to me it
depends on your relationship with God
like that's really what's most valuable
not not too bad at all to women not to
Men You're hard-pressed hard-pressed to
find a virgin today like were they at
like they're pretty non-existent right
but there's there's a plethora of girls
that'll sleep with you for before Merit
but this is just like I'm just
explaining it to you I I understand
where you're coming from and I used to
think like that but from the guy's point
of view why on Earth would he wait when
he could just like why does he have to
wait when the last guy got it for free
and then he he's not even getting him
first The Waiting should be like two
years like these these other people were
saying like I mean if you know you know
so so you think that they should wait
for married and just marriage and just
get married quick
depends on their understanding and like
what marriage is to them so like if
marriage is a covenant before God then
yes if marriage is just a piece of paper
where now you guys share assets then no
it doesn't matter right but if it's a
covenant before like you you just when
men hear that you've had a hoe phase and
then you want to get married and now
conveniently you're good with God it's
like where was that good with God when
you're a [ __ ] Tyrone and Chad it
wasn't there yeah but that's right
that's the that's the whole point that's
the whole point is like it's just it's
just mad hold on hold stop wait wait so
this is this is the whole point is that
it's just mad convenient it's like now
when you want marriage now you're right
with God it could it could be viewed
that way and I'm sure some people do do
that too but see the thing is like we're
people think oh we're all children of
God that's not true you're not a child
of God unless you're born again unless
you accept Jesus as your savior you're
not so like let's say you know you were
running a muck for the first 25 years of
your life
well when you come to know that yeah
you're evil and you need to repent then
that in that repentance comes change
right so that change that's why some
girls say I'm not going to do it till
marriage because like their relationship
with God means more than having sex or
like does that make sense no it I
understand where you're coming from I
just think it leaves women single
I think that's why when I walk into a
church I see I see so many single women
it doesn't matter catholic christian
Protestant it's just single women
everywhere
and it's because I think they're trying
to sell a used Honda Civic for BMW
prices
well but like another thing I wanted to
bring up with you too is like besides
the sex point it's like how do they
treat their man right like a lot of
women that I know like friends or
whatnot like they can become resentful
and then they withhold love and it's
like dude like you guys both have wounds
right so like when you see your man's
wounds the solution is not to then hold
back right the solution is to love him
more and like my husband's you know much
older than me right so he had a lot more
wounds than I did even though I had a
lot but because I was able to
continuously like love him like those
walls broke down right so like I feel
like that's another problem in society
where people women I want to say younger
women think that the men need to grovel
or they need to come back or they need
to beg for it and it's like okay so you
guys ultimately both want love so you're
50 of this equation right but you're
manipulating you're manipulating in a
way that's actually decreasing what you
want right so like you can't say I want
love and then pull back and play these
games games of like well I'm not going
to be this way until he's that way what
if the man says I want sex
before marriage should she cooperate
what do you mean so if she's religious
and the guy says I want to get married
to you but I want sex first should she
cooperate
well the thing is like first and
foremost she's married to Christ if
she's truly born again so like that
that's a no-go like that's just that
just doesn't happen so so would you what
if she's wishy-washy I mean yeah if she
feels she needs to give her body in
order to keep this guy but that's on her
like she has to she has to deal with
that do you think it's better to die
alone than cooperate
meaning like cooperate with having yeah
like with having sex before marriage
um I don't think so no I would never
want to die alone okay
no it's just interesting because that
just seems to be the outcome a lot of
churches are pushing
yeah I heard you say something the other
day too about like
um why would like younger men want to go
to church or like that kind of would
turn them off from that because it's
like okay these women have already been
ran through or whatnot and then now
they're saying okay we gotta wait you
know it actually would make guys it
would church right but like
the turn on for for church should be not
wanting to go to hell should be like
understanding that we either
you know accept Christ or we go to hell
like if you don't believe that or if
that's not like what's
the biggest issue then it really doesn't
matter what you do and I understand
where you're coming from but like I'm
just telling you to men it doesn't seem
genuine when all these girls happen to
come back when they need a husband
it probably isn't
okay thank you for calling in appreciate
it all right thank you
um
I actually
I wanna can we play a video would that
kill the Stream
okay okay I just I Kevin Samuels had
such a good video that okay for years I
couldn't figure out what
bothered me about church I couldn't
figure it out and I don't know my
battery PC is running low let me see
what am I at
all right Kevin Samuels
yeah hold on I'm going to send it to you
just give me a second I believe
and Cat I think yeah yeah it's this one
and I couldn't okay so I couldn't figure
out what bothered me about church and I
couldn't figure out like I couldn't put
it into words and there was two streams
one Kevin Samuels
oh no I lost that Instagram
um
foreign
let me
how am I going to send it to you because
I don't know my Instagram password
I'll put in the Google Doc
can I do that blessing
oh okay yeah do Kevin Samuels women's
nine red flags
and
this put into words what
yeah yeah can you put on the screen or
no
can you make it small on the screen is
that possible or no
okay thank you blessing's so smart
[Music]
foreign
from the beginning right yay okay
here are some things that guys need to
watch out for when they're dating
regardless of the size of your
pocketbook or your dreams or aspirations
ignore these things at your peril
because just like all the Great Men of
antiquity the Bible and in the past a
woman can need to help but oftentimes
the wrong woman can throw a man
completely into chaos start off with
this one she wants to be courted yeah
she wants to be quoted now I know
there's some guys are probably thinking
Hey Kevin you kind of talk like a
traditional man what's wrong with her
wanting to be courted nothing if she's
truly a traditional woman but typically
women want to be courted because they
want all the benefits of traditional
femininity and gender roles the thing
bringing none of that stuff to the table
this is just another way of asking you
to simp very few westernized women
deserve to be courted I say it again
very few westernized women deserve to be
courted you guys fought for equality
you're my equal you wanted equal pay you
wanted equal rights or you need to get
equal lefts you want to be courted that
ain't gonna happen we are equals deal
with it thank feminism one-on-one your
Mamas and your grandmamas this is the
world ladies if you're watching
understand this is what men are on the
lookout for so if you asking some guy to
court you what are you bringing to the
table other than sex and debt she's got
a 90-day rule or any kind of rule like
this in my opinion the first time I hear
a woman say she's got a 90-day rule I'm
out the first time I hear a woman talk
about this rule or any other kind of
rule like that I'm out just like the
United States had a policy we do not
negotiate with terrorists women can be
emotional terrorists I do not negotiate
with them because if you give a mouse a
cookie It'll ask for a glass of milk she
has a 90-day rule that automatically
implies to me that she thinks her vagina
is gold that it's something that that
gum important that I have to work strive
and earn for I don't work that hard for
anything that doesn't benefit me her
vagina ain't it because if you have
these 90 Day rules go out and blame all
these Steve Harvey type guys who told
you guys this foolishness that is man
repellent rule on day one in the other
89 days it'll be you playing with your
cat is next she's a single mother I'm
not going to ban single mothers anything
like that but bottom line there used to
be a time when a woman had a baby out of
wedlock it was few and far between and
there was some shame that went along
with it enough to where they didn't keep
going out and doing it over and over
again now it's a badge of honor you as a
man are worth too much and too valuable
if you got your head on straight you're
out doing your thing working your
business taking care of your business
you should not be forced to pick from a
crop of women who've already had another
man's children you should not have to go
out here and fight the world build such
and so forth to come home to a woman
that you will at best be the fourth or
fifth most important thing in her life
you deserve better than that I am sorry
ladies if you've had a child that is
your responsibility own it and as far as
I'm concerned stay out of the dating
scene until your kids are out of the
house you made the choice to have those
children especially if you did it
outside of wedlock you may that choice
then you make the choice to wear that
Scarlet Letter it's not our problem it's
yours guys do not date single mothers do
it at your apparel next she's a strong
independent fill in the blank woman for
me you have three times to say good five
strong Independence I'm a strong
independent blank woman I'm a strong
independent check please I'm gone
anytime that comes out of their mouth
non-negotiable in the sentence whether
it's day one or day 300 because to me
that's an underlying issue that's
waiting to burst through a person who
has to say I'm a strong independent
anything is none of the things she says
it's like if you find yourself having to
go into your house saying I'm the man of
this house you gotta say you're the man
of the house there's a problem if you
watch Game of Thrones when Joffrey says
I'm the king and Tywin told him any any
man who has to say he's the king is not
the king
strong independent blank anything needs
to be strong and dependent and alone she
believes that men and women are equals
we are not equals no male and female of
any species on the planet are equal we
are different for a reason I am not
going to negotiate Euro and my role if
you come into this saying that we're
equal we're automatically at loggerheads
because you're not a woman in my opinion
you're a female I don't date females I
date women just like the men will hear
what I'm saying the males will probably
throw shade if you want a woman that
you're equal you're really giving your
manhood up and I can't help you for the
guys out there who are trying to hear me
equality is not what is cracked up to be
typically women want equality when it
benefits them and they want to be ladies
when it suits them I don't have time for
all the back and forth because I'm
trying to do what I'm doing I'm leading
she's going to follow there can't be two
captains pick your poison if you pick
equality you'll die a slow day she's a
big time church girl I'm a Christian I
was born and raised in the church I
attend regularly but big time Church
girls tend to come with Big Time Church
problems there's no more hypocrisy in
dating than in the church because unless
she's a big time church girl and a
virgin you're already gonna have issues
oftentimes Big Time Church girls try to
use the Bible as a weapon against the
men that they date to hold you
biblically accountable for everything
that says a man should be but yet not
hold themselves biblically morally or
ethically accountable to anything that
it says a woman should be they'll tend
to take scriptures out of context use
biblical stories for their own selfish
and manipulative ends and hit you in a
place where you really can't defend your
spirituality that is the height of
manipulative deceptive bad behavior I
don't roll a big time church Bible
Thumpers but these primary reasons if it
doesn't suit you move on but you know
the kind of person I'm talking about
she's got lots of single girls okay you
can stop it you ever see a pack of
animals roaming and they that that's my
point
so it's like
the women can basically do whatever they
want come to God say sorry and still
demand Church outcomes
and if the guy doesn't go with it then
he's the bad guy for not wanting to
follow God
and and I I understand it's like the
girls will say oh I don't want to add
into my body count I don't want to make
it worse maybe I learned from my
mistakes but guys we just have to listen
to How the men hear it
this sounds crazy to men blessing you
want to wait for a born-again virgin
you put in a ring you wait until
marriage
and blessing's a a religious good dude
he's not putting no are you putting up
with that [ __ ] nah
and and this is the this is the thing
it's we're so conditioned to want
not even conditioned women want no
consequences for decisions if you made
the decision to not wait till you're
married how on Earth are you going to
demand marriage later that doesn't make
sense
feel free to do the call-in
you gotta answer
hello
hello this is Pearl you're live on the
air
hello hi what is the solution to Modern
dating going forward
so I'm calling from Cyprus I apologize
in
for my poor English but I would like to
to set some
things about the marriage subject I
believe that personally if we are
talking about traditional marriage and
church and all that stuff in fact
religion
we should first acknowledge that the
white
dress there is a purpose
for it
I I can't hear you I can hear you keep
going so you said there's a purpose for
a white dress there is a purpose for it
so as a Trader as a stock traded by
myself and I'm gonna explain that in a
while let's say now the marriage at the
moment is a contract is a traditional
thing but
in the other hand is a contract if you
are a banker or an organization you hire
an accountant you are not only count on
his trust you are counting also from the
their qualifications but if that counter
offensive way to steal money from the
organization on anything that there are
churches
so let's say now you are there is a
marriage there is a contract
let's say cheating there there are no
any churches for cheating or anything
so we have to put charges we're gonna
say yes now we are gonna make it harder
for people to imagine marriage yes but
it's going to be less divorces in other
hand as a Trader why do we say women
would prefer to know their tasks so we
know what we have to do because
um you can see the history of a stock
and you can see how it performs so you
can have a
let's say an idea what is gonna do next
yes so it's the solution
sorry I have to cut is the solution
still marriage going forward
excuse me is the solution still marriage
going forward
is the solution yeah to modern day are
you are you poor marriage or against
marriage
it's not about against marriage the
marriage
it's like we are comparing a traditional
form
factor as in a new world okay so we we
cannot combine both at the moment that's
why we have these statistics
oh you see you're saying we combine both
right now but we shouldn't
at the moment it's there is no point for
even discussion for this for my honest
opinion so let's say as I tell you if I
bet let's say if I trade for 30 to go
back but I said the history shows is
gonna go but it's gonna go down I have a
stop loss so I'm gonna stop this to
happen there are churches but on the
marriage there are no nothing no charges
it's a
it's a risky environment for a man these
days to get in involved with this
subject
with this contract that's what I'm
trying to to get yeah this idea okay
thank you just Food For Thoughts okay
thank you thank you for calling in
um do the next one
hi this is Pearl you're live on the air
hi po hi what are the solutions to
modern modern dating going forward for
men and for women
right so right so okay so we need to
backtrack a little so if I said
if I said to you that
marriage is a man-made construct in the
first place and that was strictly
designed to stop women from being
promiscuous in the first place and Men
right so
as we jump forward we're moving forward
with times there is a narrative behind I
believe that there is a narrative behind
all of this
I watch your show frequently perlier
this is Dan Rich by the way
um so yeah I'm frequently watching your
show
um but yeah I hear a lot of talk about
um uh the whole marriage concept
but it didn't really take much for us to
actually come out of it in the first
place
right look how quickly we did that I
mean post pandemic there was no talk of
this two two years ten months later it's
an epidemic right so how why the sudden
flare-up why the sudden the backtrack
now I strongly believe that
responsibility lies with parents yes
charity begins at home
if we genuinely want to raise our
children in the right way
it starts with us right the appearance
so what can we expect if children or the
young people of today are behaving in a
manner where did they get it from first
question they didn't just materialize
itself out of nowhere it had to come
from somewhere
right so if we're watching our peers and
leaders and our parents behaving in a
manner then naturally
the the children will follow
similarly when you're bringing up a
child the child doesn't know what is
dangerous what is good what is bad what
is this or anything until it's taught
right so I just I strongly believe that
we have to take responsibility adults in
general this is not about parents or any
it's just adults in general
period okay but so so the question isn't
about raising the kids it's for young
people today so people that want that's
what I mean
they're kids okay so I'm saying for
young people today young young so for
young men that want to get married
should they sign the marriage contract
yes or no and should women require
marriage before they carry
all right so in that question right so
okay I would have to say no men should
not sign the contract but there's an
answer to that so first and foremost why
would how can you sign up to something
that isn't quite there
do you know what I mean and then for the
woman
uh marry before she carries
I mean that's a pretty much far gone
already it's already gone too far okay
right so in order to before we can
actually even get down to the depths of
resolving this or even beginning to to
find a way out the responsibility I
believe lies with the adults we have to
set the agenda then the teenagers follow
so what is the agenda what should the
agenda be
well basically if adults now start to
see if adults open their eyes and just
look at what is going on
I mean how many parents how many adults
are out there saying oh this is a
travesty this is terrible this is an
outrage this is not acceptable
right but yet we're the adults we're the
ones with the experience and we're the
ones that learned we're the ones that
know we're the ones that are supposed to
be enlightened and wise right because
with age comes wisdom and experience
so how are we passing that on
so we're not clearly
we're clearly not passing that on
because if we was then we wouldn't have
the problems that are going on right now
simple as that really it's really kind
of black and white actually
do you know what I mean yeah it's just
everything you're saying is so Broad
so I it's just not well because
naturally it's it's yes
because there are so many variations of
the same thing going on hence why are
your calls everybody's got a different
perspective and a different view of
where
oh
so if I get into specifics then I'm just
covering that one particular area and
it's very easy for someone else to say
well no actually it's like this
so it's a general thing it really is a
general thing it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter about the variations the
bottom line is it's there
um
um thank you for calling
okay thank you thank you
guys okay
I try to be polite I really hate I
really hate
when I have to like tell people to stop
talking
but you can't over talk me on the call
okay second second of all
I keep asking a specific question and
getting broad answers and I need you
guys to give me specifics
because the idea of
just tell the younger generation to do
better that's a nice thought return to
traditionalism that's a nice thought but
what does that look like in practice
return to traditionalism virgins should
wait for each other
okay women should the the women that are
virgins should get to be a part of the
marriage contract no one else
okay
but when we just say
these broad statements it doesn't help
me
and it's not tonight I understand that
you can't change society I'm just
kidding if you guys had specific
Solutions what would they be
this could be a made-up one or this
could be and maybe I should have been
more specific from the job this could be
a made-up one of like an idea of a law
that we could pass like the
marriage renewals I thought that was an
interesting idea or this could be
now that the contract is so bad women
have to wait five plus years to get it
or women shouldn't require marriage
before they carry how could they expect
that that that's a specific solution so
or or there are no Solutions and dating
is screwed that could be your answer
but
tell the young people to be better
it's our fault because we're older and
we we've [ __ ] up sorry messed up I'm
trying to swear less
anyways I'm going to take two more
callers two more and then we're going to
close out the show so please last two
callers specific please be specific
hello
um please turn off the YouTube in the
background this is Pearl you're live on
the air
how you doing uh from Kentucky
um big fan by the way uh I like your
accent
oh it's kind of a mixture between
Southern and Northern here in the states
um
how to solve
this is going to be an interesting one I
don't think we can okay
I I honestly don't think we can uh the
way Society has got itself twisted and
ingrained and pretzled I don't think we
really can
do you think that
for people that want to start families
should they just not get married and
still have a family how would you do
that moving forward
I'm gonna
take this through a personal perspective
um I'm a 45 year old male of course uh I
have been single since 2010 because
early on I have seen
that I I've seen the proverbial
horse pockies hitting the fan I'm trying
to keep it clean for the chat
um
I
have opted out of dating simply because
I have had such horrible luck
trying to find somebody who is
family based
um I lost my wife and children
uh in 2004 when I was um discharged from
the military
um to a car accident and I have not been
able to get back on my feet
it's just impossible
wow
um
I I had
I she was my high school sweetheart and
we had been together for 10 years
sorry
and um
I ended up on the streets it broke me
um
and every time I gotta turn my volume
down because I hear myself on your
podcast uh
every time I have tried to re-enter the
dating game it is
it's it's more and more and more skewed
and I stopped in 2010.
I got off the streets I got myself
cleaned up I got myself straightened out
and
it has been an absolute Maze of
impossibilities I look at our laws you
you wanna you wanna fix dating
you fix the laws
you make things so that the stipulations
for consequences are so severe
people will step back and go well wait a
minute if I try to go after this man for
his money and go after his divorce and
go after him with his kid
the woman will have to stop back step
back and actually
consider
creating a problem before creating the
problem
or taking advantage
I I I've got friends who have dating
stories where they have been scammed
Time and Time and Time and Time Again
and it's just
I I don't see a solution
other than
if these people want equality let's make
them truly equal
if I divorce a woman let me take her for
half
let me take the kids
if
that's that would be true equality but
we're not we're not equal not by a long
shot
you know men have got their strengths
from birth
we are biologically ingrained
with very specific
instructions in our heads just like
women are
but for some reason women can delude
themselves out of it
you are one of the rare exceptions
see these people call themselves woke
I like to call you aware
there are two stages
you have the whole crowd the ones that
are me me me me they they sound like
they belong on a Disney musical
and then you have people like you Pearl
who have
become aware of what's going on
and I I see YouTubers all the time
um there's there's one I don't know if
I'm am I allowed to to to
name a YouTuber
one that hasn't been on your podcast
um sure yeah
okay
um I I watch a YouTuber uh her name is
the Filipina P I mentioned her when
you're uh in your live podcast a couple
days ago but I I haven't been able to
donate money because I'm still trying to
get on my feet
um
she is is a podcaster herself she she
will do uh videos on why men are going
to the east for traditional women
there are more Americans marrying
Filipino women now
because of their traditional ways
and we're not talking about the ladyboys
I know that was one of the inside jokes
um
but she is she she will tell you exactly
the reason why and I find it
I I read her um her YouTube uh chat a
lot and
I I find it funny about the women
these woke women who will literally
attack
this girl
she's only stating it as it is
I have friends who live in uh uh Vietnam
I have friends who live in South Korea
and I I talk to them all the time and
they say yeah we're seeing more
Americans over here because they're
after the tradition
the women they they're they they they're
not looking for the
um they're not looking for the the
the career they're looking for the
family
so I think
I guess
now that I've segued into this
um the best way to fix dating is to take
a really good close look at the East
well thank you for sharing the story
about your wife and kids
um that was really powerful
um I'm sorry I'm sorry that happened to
you that was really that's really a sad
story
um like I'm genuinely sorry thank you
guys I'm surprised I actually got
WhatsApp to talk to work I'm I'm a
dinosaur
um so
as uh so you think that there's no
saving modern day marriage and you think
that men should go to the east if they
do want that
I they have been okay okay
they have been I mean women women in the
west are
getting very
very irate because they the the the
these these men
who are absolutely fed up or who have
gone mgtow
are looking at the Philippines going
well I can get what I want there
and the Filipina P actually she turns
around in one of her videos and goes I
don't understand why you women are angry
you're calling these men trash we're
just taking your trash and we're happy
with it
yeah that's true I would love to see her
on your podcast I would love to see her
on your podcast I really would she is
very insightful yeah no I I haven't
heard of her but she sounds like that
sounds like something I would say you
can't be mad if men leave when you don't
give them an incentive to stay
exactly mm-hmm
exactly and then there's there it it she
states that
she actually has a reaction video I I
think it was mid-year
she did this reaction video of these
woke angry feminists
who are
giving pointers on dating
and the Filipina P at the end of her
video goes okay so basically don't date
men but date men
but this and then she has a like a list
of seven things and and it's all
contradictory they're literally eating
themselves these
these these power women they're eating
themselves they're they're eating each
other alive
well and they don't even realize they're
completely dependent on men in society
being a single woman is a privilege
exactly
and they exactly and and it's not just
it's not just Asians that are getting
these men that are fed up I I know men
are going to Egypt
mm-hmm
I I know men who are going to Africa
yeah
they're going to places that aren't the
traditional West
I'm not a guy who's going myself there I
went um there's a guy I met that was
going to Brazil he lived he he had his
YouTube videos he looks like he's living
his best life out there
Austin Holloman I think his name is the
other day you know I was the one that
turned around and mentioned you know
Brazilians Brazilian women are rated to
be the most beautiful in the world they
know how to cook they know their way to
a man's heart and they're not scared of
it
they're not gonna throw a man to the
side unless he's cheating on her then
she'll kick his ass and then kick him
out
so
I mean
well I know Egypt is in Africa Reckless
thank you
um
but I you get my point they're going to
countries that are more traditional that
will ex that want
men do you think because as you stated
before
go ahead sorry
thank you do you think those countries
will become less traditional over time
it happened to Japan it's possible it
happened to China it's possible
I mean
Hong Kong is still trying to become its
own country so
and
everything is slowly
it's possible that's all I can say is
it's possible
um yeah I don't I don't have a strong
opinion one way or the other I've just
heard I get messages from people from
all over and I've heard that happened in
India I don't know enough about it so
I'm not stating this as fact but I've
just heard India used to be a lot more
traditional in the last like
I don't know 20 30 years it's become a
lot more like modern I guess
in the past 20 to 30 years I remember as
a kid watching
um Penn and Teller do a tour I was a
this is back in the 80s they were doing
a tour of India they were trying to find
like the the people who could do the
magic rope trick
looking at their map
of India then and looking at India now
it has grown I think 50 to 75 percent
larger
because it has been
um
industrialized I guess I I don't I don't
know what happened but India blew up it
blew up Cairo
got bigger you know all these things
that are out in the middle of nowhere
got bigger
much more popular
and you can thank uh uh uh modern day
transportation for that
this guy says I'm wrong he says he's in
India now
and he says I'm wrong it's waiting in
traditional I I don't know people from
East India this is just something I've
heard people message me about I don't
actually know but okay interesting well
thank you so much for calling in I
appreciate it and I can't believe I
actually got WhatsApp to work
yeah thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
thank you for having me okay bye-bye
guys we are gonna do one more call
tonight and we're gonna finish out the
show I can only
talk for so long this has made me really
appreciate live shows because I'm like I
gotta think of a lot more things to say
when it's just me
like oh my God like in the live shows I
can be quiet for a little bit
um all right blessing you ready to
accept the final caller
all right let's give them I'm gonna give
them a second I'm gonna go three two one
open the call line and then
go ahead
oh someone said Aaron Clary is making
woman his woman pay his rent that's why
he can say it's not cohabitation oh
that's interesting
tell me when you accept it
yeah you hi this is Pearl you're live on
the air
hi Pearl how are you
doing great
um so the question is what is the
solution to Modern dating going forward
for men and for women
I think it's a a pretty tough thing to
solve
um without major like societal changes
so I just got back into the dating
Market
um I lost like a bunch of weight during
covid so I'm a lot healthier now
and I I found a woman that
um I liked a lot and she likes me
I had to kind of adjust my dating
strategy to to make this all viable I
chose
um basically to get a vasectomy before I
started dating again
I thought it was too risky to try to
navigate the waters and risk being
I don't know baby trapped by someone so
I decided to go that route I'm uh like
40 years old right now and although even
like guys don't have uh like a timeline
per se I don't really want a kid past
45. so I just took the
what I thought was the best since what I
can make the the best out of the rest of
my life and aim to have a partner that
wants to be with me
and I found like a lot of women in their
say later 30s they wanted to have a kid
more than they wanted to have a partner
so that was a big risk to me so then
like something that then back to the
marriage thing how do we solve it uh I
think from the legal standpoint you need
to
um first of all have some sort of
consequence for getting divorced there
needs to be
shame let's say that brought in
um the legal challenges that needs to be
you know in terms of Family Court treat
men as having 50 50 custody as a default
and you would have to prove why that
should not be the case men should not be
giving up additional resources to try to
get back to 50 50 in terms of child
custody
um so a number of
changes that way the way that marriage
is currently written it still has
Traditional Values in mind and it hasn't
really kept up with the rest of society
um in terms of what can we do to women
to make
what can they do differently and I kind
of feel like oh sorry no um yeah sorry
keep going go keep going it's not it's
not what sorry sorry it's not what can
women do differently it's like what
should women do now so do women require
marriage before they have children do
they still should they still require
marriage
um how long should they wait if so how
long should they wait to get married
like what what is a woman's blueprint
going forward
I think
um you need to spend something on the
order of probably like a year together
be in a committed relationship I mean
that's what marriage meant before
anyways being committed to each other so
um as long as someone's committed you
don't necessarily need the contract to
prove that's the case
um
like I think if the guy's willing to
show the woman to his family and vice
versa that's obviously like a pretty
good sign like you have to kind of build
upon that
and uh share some of your life together
before you should start creating kids
together
um I'm curious do you have children
no I don't okay and so would you by
getting the vasectomy are you would you
if you found the right girl would you
reverse it or no
oh okay
you guys like that was my goal in the
end I mean I was never
super gung-hobo
um having kids right now anyways
like I said I was overweight from from
both 30 until just like a couple years
ago so I never even bothered dating for
about 10 years and just got back into
the market
um within the past couple years or so
okay so I think I think there needs to
be like um I think educating uh the
younger generation to show what are
these various options that you have if
you wanna if you want to focus on hard
career and you want to be
um like a boss babe so I had to go ahead
and do that but then understand the
consequences of what that means
and understand that like uh women are
going to be on a timeline I think you
need to reinforce women being more
effeminine and men being more masculine
and uh cater meant to be in those like
leadership roles I think that would help
out men be stronger as well and then
become more desirable to women
so like a lot of those things take time
to
to change and I don't see if it's
changing overnight some of the legal
um things I talked about could I could
change people with the right political
party and power let's say but
even that would take years to implement
and I just like for me personally
because I'm already 40. I didn't see
that changing in a timely enough fashion
to uh to try to like form the rest of my
life on
no and it's interesting I never even
thought of a vasectomy as an option for
men but
I just didn't want to get baby trapped
by someone yeah and valid fear there's a
couple of situations where because I was
dating a lot um the end of last year and
I'm in a committed relationship there's
a couple of times that gave me a few
scares and I'm glad I had that surgery
he's like I'm not playing it's not ideal
I'm not I'm not playing with you it's
not it's not a good it's not a good end
game plan because yeah I know that if
every guy did what I did
um then there's no new kids there's no
new generation right yeah
okay well um this that was interesting
so thank you for calling in
um I never even thought of the second
thanks for having me yeah I think thank
you
okay that's that's our last caller for
the night so
guys we had some interesting ideas I
liked the renewal the marriage license
renewal that's an interesting solution
um
I like the idea of like the new
generation focusing on them they wait
but I don't think that's probable
likely especially I see what's going on
in high school these days they're wild
oh my God
um a vysectomy that's interesting
do we have any other interesting ones
my laptop died otherwise I'd read from
my notes
um I it seems like moving forward a lot
of it seems like the new Norm may not
even be marriage it may just be
long-term relationships
actually that could be that could be a
whole stream should women require
marriage before they carry
anyways guys um thank you for watching
thank you for the super chats I'm going
to read the ones that I see but I got my
laptop died so I was looking at my phone
very nice socks from the
The Naughty Bear
um
I think that's yeah sorry that's that's
as far as it goes back but thank you
guys for the super chats like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and let me know if you guys like these
call-in shows we can do them more often
I I
yeah let me know if you guys prefer this
or you prefer the live show because you
know maybe we can mix in one or two if
you guys like these subscribe to the
Channel I want to get to 700k uh before
the end of the month that's my goal like
the video